a lot of people will be wondering are  you two meeting just because you know  you're similar in age and you know got a  lot of you know Common stuff there you  know when you got into politics and  stuff or can kiwis actually expect to  see more deals between our two countries  down the line because there is my first  question is I wonder whether or not  anyone ever asked Barack Obama and John  key if they met because they were of  similar Age We of course have a higher  proportion of men in politics it's  reality because two women meet it's not  simply because of the agenda yeah we are  meeting because we are prime ministers  of course  that prime minister uh yeah I know  that's not Aaron might drop there